[Music]
welcome back to another chapter of dirty
RT chapter 11 my name is Rob joined here
with Jake Jake we had a very interesting
last episode we had we saw the darker
side of dirty RT we did there
aka such a thing aka Pig man and pig man
what about Valentine and he murdered and
he hurt a lot of people there and we
figured this chapter we're gonna go back
and we're gonna make amends with the
folk of Valentine we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna come back and bring
some good-natured dirty already and what
better way to do that than to act as a
doctor and supply health and medicine
and doctor art dr. Rd is what we are
going to bring to Valentine and see if
we can you know make peace with
Valentine and and just show show them
our love for that beautiful beautiful
mud and they do supplies with a lot of
mud they do so we're gonna we're gonna
make our way back to Valentine and do
just that we have a nice little doctor
cap it's actually a miner's cap but
we're gonna call it a doc it kind of
looks like the reflector thing on like
yeah the doctors use I don't know if
that's called but uh which you know
neither does dirty arty so it'll be
perfect for this totally it looks like
you had some gloves or no that those are
our hit man gloves huh they are I tried
to get lighter ones but they don't look
that light now in the Sun whatever
let's find dr. gloves they're all the
same yeah so I also noticed as you were
preparing for this chapter that this
horse looks a little different oh yeah
so there's a story behind that I'd like
to hear it so I was looking for a lab
coat this is about as close as I got so
I went into a store I left my horse
outside as you do I you know got my lab
coat got the gloves maybe bots an ammo
some food walked outside my horse was
dead on the ground I didn't do it I
swear
wasn't your fault it wasn't my fault we
need to get some medicine - right right
so you know considering the Arsenal that
dirty already has some tools can be
determined I'm thinking sage when you
say we need sage it's a great it's a
great herbal medicine and it works well
with knives throwing knives specifically
so you know to deliver medicine properly
dirty Artie needs to have some means of
throwing it so he's gonna throw medicine
at people I'm drawn to heal you I think
I think you have you look sick a regular
one in a poison just died right away I
question I think it's for like bigger
animals I mean I don't know maybe it's
like a it's a really potent medicine you
know I like to think or dirty already
likes to think that they're going to
sleep just for a little bit and then
when they when they wake back up they'll
be okay they feel better yeah who watch
medicine you need some food bring them
go okay so I think we should take him as
a lab rat yeah we need to kind of tests
what medicines work what don't because
you know it is the 1800s
technically right yeah they haven't
really figured out medicine that well Oh
who's this oh he wasn't kiddin put him
next to each other and let's decide
which one gets gets the medicine which
one does alright first we got to make
the incision whoa oh my god I do we need
to sterilize our Oh Senor Thurmond water
or or we start a little bit of a fire
this is a nice tall grass let's start a
little
I earn and whichever one gets caught on
fire first we'll save the one we'll save
the one that that is not sterilized so
I'll throw it right here
there isn't much luggage it logic in any
of this but for dirty are he it makes a
lot of sense to me yeah that's good oh
here we go oh alright I'll save you
hurry hurry I can't and won't let me
pick them up oh oh there it is well we
lost them both of our lab rats one thing
that I also want to point out that
people might notice that Artie's beard
is just a little bit longer
it sure is it's at level 9 now hopefully
soon we'll have a max beard but it is
level 9 though before we're at 8 we're
at 8 for like the past I don't know five
episodes maybe you know just got to keep
at it then Oh Oh howdy partner you
thought oh if I just hide out of sight
the doctor will leave me alone oh my god
oh oh and then drop them oh yeah steer
them to the left and then just let it go
oh this is wonderful
oh look oh there's my horse
go home when I land on the horse didn't
quite happen
I could see your intention well that was
fun
well that was fun his little open-air
therapy yeah he just needs to rest now
what do you think he'll be good it was
infected we did him a favor little
amputee service there we should do more
of that we should be doing ya
amputations yeah you're probably right
that's the best service we can provide
it is the 1800s
I'm trying to practice medicine can't
you see him with a patient right now
oh yeah if you D this is our bone saw
yeah that's exactly what that is a bone
sawed off shotgun
you should amputate someone's head oh
you think so yeah
you're welcome look at all those people
I healed down there in the corner yeah
look at all those people it's a shame
that you have to pay the bill with that
bounty I know right well I've made it to
Valentine but they don't really want me
here they don't know yet I mean maybe
it's cuz you're your doctor's hat fell
off
oh you know what probably right know
what mister looks like you got a
headache they're all better this is the
sixth time it finally ends with just let
let her be let her be there oh just okay
we're back we're back in our seat
what the hell all right let's try that
again slow why won't you sit put put her
on the horse until your horse - get out
get out of here yep right through town
perfect that's all we wanted cover's
blown
you have unorthodox methods but they do
work my god they weren't oh this looks
like a good place to apply some medicine
I think so
Oh you should throw her off I mean you
should give her medicine right over here
off the cliff here and seeing if these
marshals can take a look at her oh oh oh
my god you are really asking for it
I think that'll think that'll cure yeah
all right now this might hurt just a
little bit it's kind of like a band-aid
this will teach you to leave the post
office for once some outdoor medicine
take one of those call me in the morning
I'm the rest damnit yeah taking to you
now we're gonna have we're gonna get
back in that town we're gonna give that
town Valentine the medicine it needs out
of my house quickly goes this room good
to be home
oh wow
[Laughter]
hold on let me fix your face yeah jump
off like we do all right time to go to
our practice yeah let's go talk to the
doctor in house the doctor the doctor
actually does light up yeah yeah it
works at night you're calling his
medicine Kyle she leaves I'm dying my
firm yeah get on that I mean I guess I
could leave since I don't wait for him
[Laughter]
[Music]
but one person you don't want to see
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're the doctor now who cares you live
oh he's totally dead hell yes
all right what do you want one at a time
one at a time you got to be in my store
got so impatient all right
invitation for you advil for you oh
let's just fix that and that we've cured
the town no solid day's work Carter eyes
[Music]
not too bad
yes my boy like dirty Artie's redesign
of the doctor's office it's a much
better doctor's office now yeah it's
real nice over here yeah go figure we're
closed
can't you tell by the fire what oh it's
on fire
well Valentine doesn't like art healing
no they don't they don't take us
seriously
if you even think about trying to kill
someone I'll shoot you dead just a
reminder you guys just opened up a new
realm yeah for sure
[Laughter]
all right come on my party come on mark
get up on there get up there Mike didn't
I just kill you whoa you want some
medicine Oh
accept it accept it I'll be doing the
world a favor
Oh a dog got a dog
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright let's find let's find one more
soul to heal okay a stranger all along
the side of the road and we'll call it a
stomach every step of the way everyone
saw like a bar full of people saw me
shoot that guy in the whole town just
some of you run over five people like
the police report would be so specific
everyone everyone saw you leave everyone
in the hotel saw all that [ __ ] you to
your beds
I didn't kill him perfect oh no your dog
get your dog I'm trying to fix you okay
sorry
yeah I think something's wrong with your
shooting hand some arthritis right there
oh dosage was a little too high he got
he's kind of like a reverse Wolverine
there oh yeah you're right oh no the the
cattle is the cattle is frightens you
should you should call them let me punch
them you punch it before I know I used
to punch it all the time that used to be
my favorite thing to do now I can't
punch cows maybe just needs a little
medicine I'm a veterinarian now and
sometimes the best medicine is just put
it out of its misery
yeah oh oh no no oh we can't have this
[Music]
yeah I think I think we have done our
best as a doctor which isn't saying much
yeah we did our best
at least let Mike survive rather episode
okay okay all right well that's gonna do
it for a dirty arty this week thank you
all for stopping by and check it out
this week's charities us before we go we
have we've got some images to look at
we've got some artis to look at he got
some more artists look I thanks to you
guys for submitting them to our Twitter
turtle boy 1380 he's
send it to me on Twitter and he says I
call this one I wear red so you don't
see the blood that seems fitting dirty
Rd gets a lot of blood on him he dies
way to mask it next one we have is from
Tacitus Kilgore 13 and he said hey there
just wanted to say love what you folks
do with the arty series here's my
version of dirty already hope you like
it looks great I like the pants I like
the they're like skinny jeans the hoes
are good pants I like the clothes or
whatever yeah let's say if if Artie were
ever to wear shoes or Footwear it would
have to be it would have to be it those
look real comfy next we have fishing guy
88 I like it once again already Crockett
Hardy Crockett now once again the
raccoon hat looks great I like that
jacket
classic dirty already hat Johson Slayer
here yeah look at that he's he's quite
literally dirty and in the pin here with
him sheep some smelly friends I think
that's favorite town yeah Tyler Phillip
Tyler Phillips there that's the pig man
cometh oh and his horse's name is schizo
the raggedy [ __ ] that looks like one of
those the Murphy Murphy horses because
it looks real gross raggedy yeah one of
those scabby horses I love it all so
this is this is probably the most
threatening photo of the law and lastly
we had smarty arty smarty arty from
spooky ghosty I believe is who this is
from another shout out to someone made a
Twitter account for dirty arty called
arty dirty and so yeah you should follow
that it was responding to some of our
tweets and it was her pretty funny I
love it yeah that's great yeah you guys
are all great thank you for submitting
your Artie's and do it again next week
and we'll include them that's a hashtag
show us your arty all right well thank
you guys so much think
Jake and have a great rest of your week
bye now
[Music]